what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime out Pro and today I will be
talking about the strongest quirks in
boku no hero that changed over time to
become stronger and sometimes
drastically different from what they
were before I am NOT talking about
quirks that just became stronger because
the user trained harder rather I will be
discussing quirks that underwent a
fundamental change either an awakening
are reawakening after they were
initially suppressed or an outright
evolution that made them far more opie
than they were before real quick before
we get into it big thank you to raid
Shadow legends for partnering with us to
make this video possible let's face it
you probably heard about this game
unless you've been hiding under a rock
or something and even if you were that
rock was probably brought to you by raid
Shadow legends seriously though raid
Shadow legends is a new collection RPG
game that blew up recently with almost
15 million downloads in the last six
months so far rate has been breaking the
Internet as a mobile game but now the
big news is that raid is finally
available for PC and Mac that's right
you can now enjoy the top tier graphics
and epic action on the big screen with
all of your gaming gear at your disposal
the download is super quick and easy and
once its installed it's always available
on your desktop best of all the game is
free to download and play I really
enjoyed the strategic gameplay huge boss
fights compelling storyline and over 400
champions for you to collect and
customize my champion waifu is
definitely El hane she has a beautiful
design and epic moves you have to check
it out for yourself
just go to the video description click
on the special links and you will get
50,000 silver and a free epic champion
as part of the new player program to
start your journey if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications quick warning this video
will contain
kouno hero manga spoilers we're talking
about all the available information in
the manga so far so please proceed with
caution you have been warned first up
let's start things off with gettin a
prominent member of the paranormal
Liberation Army who possesses an ice
based quirk gettin' is a fiercely loyal
member of the paranormal Liberation Army
and he is completely dedicated to the
Army's leader read estro for his part
rhe destro values get in highly and he
entrusts him with very important
missions jetan skwerkel aus him to
manipulate ice and gettin spent his
entire life training his quirk in order
to make it as strong as possible when we
first meet him in the story get inspire
is very impressive he can manipulate
vast quantities of ice at great
distances allowing him to practically
encase an entire town in ice if he wants
to he is able to use his ice to attack
opponents to defend himself against
opponents and to move around quickly on
top of the ice even moving through the
air with great speed getting squirt thus
gives him incredible offense/defense
and maneuverability and his use of the
ice based power is highly sophisticated
he doesn't just launched a few icicles
at his opponent here and there rather he
can use his quirk to create massive and
intricate ice based structures that he
can use for short-range medium-range and
long-range attacks in Chapter two three
four read Astro explains to Shiga rocky
that gettin squirt wasn't always what it
is now during a pivotal moment get its
quirks suddenly evolved and became
stronger namely at some point in the
past gettin's boss read Astro suffered a
burn and get and suddenly learned not
only to use ice but also to manipulate
the temperature of ice something that he
could not do before he spontaneously
unlocked this ability in order to help
his commander deal with the burn but now
that he has learned to use this type of
temperature manipulation he is able to
make his quirk even stronger for
instance he is now able to instantly
turn
quantities of water into ice and then
use that ice in whichever way he sees
fit he can turn all the water inside the
underground pipes of a city into ice and
then use all that ice to his advantage
basically turning all the water in a
city into a deadly weapon and we can
only imagine what an advantage getint
would have over his opponents if he was
fighting them on the beach or saved
beside a river next up let's talk about
Himiko toga and her mysterious blood
sucking quirk called transform when we
eventually learned the true nature of
togas quirk we realized that she has the
ability to physically transform herself
into another person if she is able to
consume enough of that person's blood so
she can mimic all of the physical
details of that person's appearance and
she can also mimic their voice this is
obviously an extremely useful quirk when
it comes to tricking people spying and
gathering Intel but the difficult part
with using this quirk is gathering
enough of the targets blood toga needs
to drink a significant amount of her
target's blood in order to transform and
stay transformed for a significant
period of time
she needs roughly one full cup of blood
in order to transform into someone for
one day so it isn't enough for her to
just gather a few drops of blood during
a battle she needs to find a way to get
more than that and it would be pretty
hard for someone not to notice that toga
drank so much of their blood unless they
were knocked unconscious or something
along those lines
at first this purely physical
transformation is all togas quirk could
do she could look and sound like another
person but she could not mimic their
unique abilities such as their quirks
however in Chapter two to 6 when she is
badly injured and on the brink of death
toga
suddenly experiences a quirk awakening
and she becomes capable of not only
transforming into someone else
physically but she also learns to
actually use that person's quirk in that
moment she is able to transform into or
Chico and use or Chacos quirk zero
gravity what's more she is able to use a
quirk very effectively against a large
number of enemies at the same time it
seems that after the
illusion of her quark toga is now able
to copy and use the quirk of anyone that
she transforms into as long as she has
seen the quark in action and knows how
it works
needless to say while the ability to
change her physical appearance into
someone else was useful for spying and
Intel gathering the power to also copy
that persitz quark changes the game
completely
as long as toga consumes enough blood
from multiple people she is able to
transform into those different people at
will and with her awakened quark this
means that she will now be able to use
all of their quirks in battle I'm sure
this will take some training to master
but by learning the ability to copy
quirks on top of just copying someone's
physical appearance toga has transformed
into a completely new villain a villain
that is far more dangerous than she was
before now let's talk about another
member of the league of villains the one
and only twice get it I said one and
only but his whole thing is making
clones of himself
anyway twice is the mentally disturbed
villain who is capable of creating
clones of himself or others as long as
he knows the precise measurements and
characteristics of that which he is
copying the clones that twice creates
will not be as strong as the original
and if the clones take enough damage
they will simply dissolve into mud the
amount of damage required to destroy a
clone is roughly equivalent to suffering
a broken limb when we first meet him
twice doesn't want to make clone 2
himself because in the past his clones
began fighting over who is the real
twice and who is the clone and this led
to complete chaos so instead of cloning
himself twice uses his quirk to create
clones of other members of the league of
villains such as Dobby but he can only
create two clones at a time however
eventually twice becomes willing to make
clones of himself again and in Chapter
230 his quirk evolves in such a way that
he is able to create a virtually
infinite amount of clones his clones
start making more clones and they
multiply rapidly filling up entire city
blocks and absolutely overwhelming every
opponent in sight with the sheer
strength of numbers it has been
suggested that if his quark is used to
its full potential
twice could over
an entire country by himself now my
inclusion of twice here might be a bit
controversial because his ability to
create infinite doubles could just be
classified as a super move called sad
man's parade so it's not necessarily
that his quirk has fundamentally changed
rather he was able to finally overcome
the trauma of cloning himself in the
past which allowed him to clone himself
again and then those clones clone
themselves in turn since they all
possess the same quirk and then before
you know it an army of twice's
appears nevertheless due to the drastic
difference that twice's use of the
infinite doubles makes in battle
compared to any other use of his quirk I
have to count double as one of the
strongest quirks that has changed since
the story began his quirk may not have
changed on a biological level but going
from making only one or two clones of
other people to an army of clones that
can overwhelm entire cities and perhaps
even countries is a drastic change in
the use of his quirk that I simply
cannot ignore any pro hero including the
very strongest ones would have a very
difficult time dealing with twice as
powers as they are right now and that is
why he simply has to be on this list now
let's talk about the leader of the
league of villains and the successor of
all-4-one Tamura shigaraki
and his quark decay shigaraki square
evolved during the very same arc that
toga and twice as quirks evolved which
was the paranormal Liberation Army arc
when the boku no hero story begins
shigaraki squirt requires him to touch
an object or a person with all five of
his fingers in order for the decaying
quirk to activate at that point the
object being touched will begin to
disintegrate with the decay spreading
all over the object or person until they
are reduced to dust the decay is able to
spread through solid objects but not
through other types of substances like
sand however during the fight with Reed
Astro shigaraki squirt changes it
becomes awakened much like togas quirk
shigaraki learns to activate his quirk
without needing to touch the target with
all five fingers but beyond that he
unlocks a power that his crook had
before
but which he had subconsciously
repressed as a result of his tragic
childhood after his quirks awakening
shigaraki is able to make his decay
spread from object to object and from
person to person at an incredibly quick
rate instead of disintegrating one
person at a time or one object at a time
he is able to disintegrate entire crowds
entire buildings and even entire city
blocks almost instantly just by touching
one target that happens to be connected
to the others so for example by touching
the street he can disintegrate everyone
and everything on the street including
buildings people and so on the sheer
power and destructive potential of
shigera Keys awaken quark cannot even be
compared to how his quark was at the
beginning of the series and thanks to
this awakening shigaraki has become a
far more serious and far more dangerous
villain than he once was finally let's
talk about the one quark that has been
changing the most since the beginning of
the story a quark that is in the process
of becoming seven different quirks that
will one day all be at the disposal of
its user the quark I'm talking about is
none other than one for all and the user
is of course Deku after a strange black
substance begins emanating from Deku in
Chapter 210 it is eventually revealed
that Deku is going to manifest six more
quirks on top of the quark that he
already possesses which is one for all
this is because the quark one for all
itself is growing and as a quirk that
stockpiles power and then transfers
those powers on to other users one for
all has actually been stockpiling the
different quark factors of its previous
holders within its core with that said
no previous user of one for all was ever
able to use the other six quirks but for
some reason dec who has started
manifesting these additional quirks so
far he has only been able to manifest
one of the six additional quirks and
that quirk is called black whip as the
name suggests this quirk allows its user
to generate powerful black whips from
his body and these whips can be used to
grab
and people dec who is unable to use the
whips effectively at first and he needed
to practice and train before he could
make effective use of this new quirk
when I first read the manga and saw this
development when I realized that deca
was going to be manifesting six more
quirks on top of the already overpowered
quirk that he possesses I was pretty
disappointed
Deku is already so insanely op4 a mere
high school student and when we take
into account that he inherited his quirk
later on in life it didn't have his
entire life to learn how to use it even
his current powers and abilities are
arguably quite broken so when I learned
that on top of that deck who would be
able to use six more powerful quirks I
had no idea what horikoshi was thinking
and I'm still pretty iffy about this
revelation because I do think that Deku
is more than strong enough as he is now
but the arc that followed this
revelation in the manga did go pretty
far in allowing us to understand where
horikoshi is coming from it was in the
very next arc to paranormal Liberation
Army arc that toga twice and shigaraki
became far far stronger than they were
thanks to the evolutions of their quirks
not to mention that the next arc also
saw began to machia joining the league
of villains and shigaraki undergoing a
procedure to become even stronger with
the help of Fujiko only after reading
the paranormal Liberation Army arc that
I realized why Dec who was given yet
another major powerup it is because the
villains and shigaraki in particular
have just been given a massive buff and
Deku will need additional powers in
order to keep up with shigaraki and the
villains especially when it comes to
longer range attacks with that said I am
still concerned about how Dec whose new
powers will be handled in the story
because power creep has now become a
potential issue and once Deku masters
all seven of his quirks it is possible
that he will become so strong that all
the other characters in the story will
become insignificant by comparison we'll
have to wait and see but in the meantime
let me know what you guys think about
the evolution and awakening of these
powerful quirks are you a fan of this
development does the idea of other
quirks evolving in cool new ways excite
you or are you afraid that power
will become an issue also what do you
think about the reveal that deck who is
going to manifest six more quirks and
why is that good the first one for all
user who gets to enjoy this privilege
feel free to give me your opinion
whether they are positive negative or
somewhere in between down in the
comments below if you enjoy this video
and you want to see more bok'nor your
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know it
definitely helps and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification belt
to turn on all notifications once again
a big thank you to our sponsor raid
shadow legends for making this video
possible
be sure to check the game out for free
links in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]